hello everyone and welcome to game two
of the 2021 world chess championship
match between magnus carlsen and
yanipanishi yeah it's a great game you
guys are going to enjoy it and before we
check it out i would just like to
mention uh about the time format as
there seems to be a confusion in my
previous video or rather i misspoke
so the time format is um
120 minutes for the first 40 moves so
each player gets two hours for the first
40 moves then you get an additional hour
for the next 20 moves and then uh upon
reaching move 60 you get an additional
15 minutes plus it's only as of move 61
that
the the increment
is being put into action so there is no
time increment before move 61. so just
uh wanted to get that out of the way and
also you guys requested that i added the
rating so these are their classical
ratings you can see that magnus is 28 55
and nipple here 2782
and that you would also enjoy some
photos so i i decided to throw in a few
of them we're gonna throw in uh a few uh
every game so i hope you guys enjoyed
that as well so here is a nice photo of
gary kasparov uh he he joined them at
the the world championship venue um here
having a good time with sheikh nayan
mabarak
i have no idea who that is but uh they
seem to be having a good time if you
guys know to do sharing the comments uh
and here is a is a good moment of nipple
arriving at the game magnus arrived
early today nippo is now joining him uh
there's the hanching you can see it's a
very firm handshake and there's no eye
contact as usual it's very very rare
that you will see eye contact when
players shake hands before the game
maurice of course looking at jan he's
not uh looking at magnus he doesn't want
to upset him as he is one of the peop a
few people that managed to upset magnus
quite a lot uh during that one interview
if you remember and you know as usual if
you check
if you you know uh find anything weird
with any of the photos do do mention
uh in the comments you can see that
magnus does not have any corporate logos
on his jacket which is not true they're
just on the other side of the jacket
something also uh in interesting uh and
here is the moment where the first move
was made the first move was made by fide
president arkadie vorkovich and he
played the move e4 which is not the move
that magnus wanted to play uh but that's
uh you know uh normal because the person
that makes the move they they just make
any move and then the player either
leaves that move or he makes another
move but you can see that here carlson
is enjoying himself he's uh you know
smiling as of course he knows he he will
not play the e4 move but nepo doesn't
know that so nepo uh looks at d4 and
already he's probably deep uh into the
game you know what if magnus plays e4
would i well you know uh
you can see the the difference in
posture in in you know just just
everything uh so that's a little bit you
know about the scene so you guys can get
more into the mood of the game so now
let's get oh and one more thing uh of
course uh i was planning on
replacing their profile photos here so i
found a beautiful photo of magnus by
nikiriga
from the opening gala of the of the
world championship match uh but i did
not find a better photo of nipple than
this one because you you cannot find a
good photo of nepal any any any time a
photographer approaches him he will make
faces like this like
i i'm not even kidding like you can
check any photo it's like that or he has
all you know both of his hands in his
face so it's very hard to find a good
photo or nip or nipple that's why i'm
always using this one but you guys are
more than welcome to correct me if you
find a good photo uh from the uh 2021
world championship match do send it to
me i will of course very very happily
replace it but at some point i will also
find one and and replace it as a lot of
you were requesting uh you know uh uh
updated photos uh so that being said uh
let's check out the game uh magnus now
with the white pieces uh retreats uh
with this e4 pawn back to e2 that arcade
vorkovich played and uh he plays pawn to
d4 and this is where our game really
starts uh we have knight to f6 by nipple
uh c4 we have e6 knight to f3 uh sort of
um not interested in going for the names
of indian if you play knight to the c3
then maybe this would be too sharp uh
for for a world championship match even
though you know uh in the talbot phoenix
wheelchair championship match we did
enjoy a nice name so indian but here we
have knight to f3 sort of the anti-names
of indian uh and now striking in the
center with the d5 transposing into the
queen's gambit declined we have g3 by
magnus he goes for the catalan opening
and the bishop to e7 now with bishop to
g2 castles by nepal castles by magnus
and now d captures on c4 so this is uh
the sharpest line but the one would
expect no less from a world championship
match uh queen to c2
uh preparing to take back the pawn and
now
there are a couple of ideas here the the
most often played one is just a6 a6
preparing b5 and a6 is usually met with
a4 stopping b5 and at some point white
just uh grabs the pawn but here nepo
shows uh his preparation and he plays b5
he defends the pawn right away and he
says i don't care about this knight the
e5 does not represent any
any you know anything of interest
because if this was good you know people
would people would play it and indeed no
one plays knight to e5 here so after b5
as this is a known move people just play
a4 i mean why wouldn't you black over
extend it here you just want to attack
his pawn structure and you can't really
defend it if you play c6 we can just
capture for example captures calculus
knight to g5 and it's well close to
winning for white
because you're going to lose this rook
and of course
you can play knight to d5 which is your
main defensive resource
against ideas like this because you're
gonna get checkmated with queen to h7 so
this is the idea so probably uh most
likely after a4 we would see bishop to
b7 and the white wins back the pawn with
a capture and b5 leaving black with a
weak pawn here on c4 so this is what
what usually happens but magnus says
nope after b5 he just goes knight to e5
even though no one plays this or rather
almost no one uh now the rook is
attacked and how do you defend this uh
there are a couple of ways you can do
this and it's not all that easy to
choose between them for example you
could go knight to d5
and then we uh go into something similar
for example a4c6 and and the game
continues uh another interesting idea
after knight to e5 is what about the d4
pawn maybe we can just grab this pawn
well if queen captures and d4 happens
then we have this very interesting
knight captures an f7 idea
uh just saying uh because by playing
queen captures on d4 uh you're offering
this this rook for the knight on e5 but
white will say i'm just going to grab a
pawn uh you know while i'm at it we're
going to play c6 now we're going to
defend the rook and now the knight goes
back knight to g5 and the white can be
very happy here black has you know
a messed up pawn structure that e6 pawn
is very weak
and he shouldn't have any problems but
nepo continues in a most solid way after
knight ae5 he just plays c6 uh now his
structure is even more defended and uh
you cannot play bishop characters on a8
uh magnus of course uh could continue uh
in a variety of ways for example the c6
pawn is hanging now you could capture it
with knight captures and c6 knight
captures and bishop captures but it
isn't um much to look at we're going to
play rook to b8 we're going to defend
our b5 pawn and if anything this only
helps the black develop another thing
you could do
after this c6 move is maybe just further
undermined the spawn chain with b3 uh as
it was played in the game ahmed ali
versus masks maxim matlakov in the in
the grand swiss this year uh the game
ended in a draw but the game continued
with queen captures on d4 attacking the
rook bishop to b2 and now queen back to
b6 so it's a very active way to play but
uh
maybe a bit too active for a world
change championship game so instead
after c6 uh magnus just goes for a4 and
this is now a new move uh already as of
move nine uh so let's see how niapa
deals with this he goes knight to d5 and
this is uh
the most solid way to to play this if
you try something like b4 which of
course uh is uh
always an option uh it's not uh
it's not much because the the c4 pawn
will hang and uh
well you want to you want to keep this
tension for for as long as possible so
here knight the d5 and the knight here
is very very useful as it controls
before it controls c3 you can play maybe
c5 at some point so the
rook on a8 will not be hanging and now
magnus just continues with knight to c3
he attacks the knight here and now b4
is definitely something to consider
because if it works uh you know could be
could be very interesting uh for example
if b4 knight to e4 we could play bishop
to a6 now get to the bishop on this
diagonal we're gonna capture the pawn on
c4 but now uh knight to d7 for example
and after let's say rook to d1 we're
gonna play b3 with black and it's uh
it's a completely crazy position queen
captures on b3 rook b8 we get our rook
away from this nasty diagonal attack the
queen on b3 after the queen moves we can
even play knight to b4 attack the queen
and after queen to b3 well who knows we
might even see a repetition knight e5
queen d3 knights to b4 queen to b3 so
even
ideas like these are possible so we
don't see b4 here and nipple goes for
the absolute sharpest and the quite
quite uh possibly strongest idea and
that is f6 he chases away the knight
from e5 and now uh what does magnus play
uh he of course goes uh
knight back to f3 uh and now if you guys
are interested about the situation on
the clock nipple is um
uh uh
some one one hour and 28 minutes uh uh
some one hour and 28 minutes on the
clock whereas magnus is some one hour
and 50 minutes on the clock uh so not
really uh wasting all that much time in
here uh nipple has to decide how to how
to play here and he plays queen to d7
but here was another moment where one
could consider b4 and b4 in this
position is an extremely dangerous move
i'm just going to show you one line that
could occur for example b4 uh we're
going to play knight to e4 and now we're
going to play bishop to a6 uh so what do
you play here knight to c5 we pressure
the bishop bishop captures on c5 d
captures on c5 and now even knight to d7
going after the c5 pawn uh we're gonna
chase away the knight with e4 and now
there's this very nasty b3 idea by black
queen can move uh for example if you
play queen to d2 uh we can even play c3
so there are ideas like this attacking
the queen also this now exposes the rook
to the bishop so if you want to avoid
this you're going to have to play some
like queen to d1 now comes knight to b4
and i'll look at all of these squares
that are available for for yon's knights
so this is only
one one thing that could happen but
nipple's time is uh
running uh out very very quickly so he
doesn't want to spend all that much time
considering this b4 move but
interestingly a b4 move seems to be the
crucial idea in every game with black or
white so here nipple goes queen to d7 uh
also a fine way to continue developing
your pieces he wants to develop and you
know his pieces can just stay like this
forever he has to bring this knight to
a6 to c7
and get some pieces into the game now
magnus plays e4 chases away this knight
from d5 we have knight to be for
attacking the queen and the queen to e2
now
so what do you play here well you could
continue with your plan for example
knight a6 knight to c7 then you bring
the bishop into the game but nepo places
the knights to d3 right away and you
could say that okay maybe the threat is
stronger than the execution maybe leave
the knight on b4 so you can play at the
d3 at some point but he chooses to do it
right away and now there are
some very very interesting choices here
and you have to really uh you know it's
hard to pick for example eight captures
and b5 can be played uh that's always an
an interesting choice after you capture
this then you go after the pawn chain
with b3 so that's something that you can
go for you could play bishop to h3 also
very interesting just going after that
e6 pawn making d5 a thread but then
queen to b7 comes and it's not all that
impressive anymore so uh here magnus
goes for the absolute sharpest idea
after knight to d3 he plays e5 and now
he invites ian to play b4 as he just
freed up this e4 square for his knight
but not only that he also opens up this
diagonal once again and now a captures
and b5 is a threat yet again so here the
situation on the clock is uh
an hour and 28 minutes for magnus and an
hour for 12 minutes for nipple uh here
we have bishop to be seven by nipple the
again the the absolute sharpest here is
just f5 not allowing e captures and f6
which is also kind of a threat uh but it
i believe it would require just too much
time to calculate this for example a
characteristic b5 now you can't capture
because your rook would hang you would
have to go bishop to b7 and now there's
this bishop to g5 idea and now after we
move the bishop now we're going to play
knight to e1 we have to get this knight
away from d3 it's just a menace here so
c captures on b5 we're going to play
bishop captures on b7 queen captures on
b7 knight characters on d3 c captures
queen captures and now this bishop
captures and c3 move saying that if you
capture with the pawn which is you know
something everyone would do then you
create a past a pawn for black and it
can be very dangerous you're gonna have
to play queen captures probably rook the
c8 and the game continues so this is
what uh uh something that could happen
if you know uh you play uh the the
absolute best with black or you know
according to our good uh silicon friend
uh so after e5 we have bishop to b7 by
nipple right away as we already
mentioned after captures you're going to
have to play bishop to b7 you're not
going to have time to recapture here so
e captures on f6 we have bishop captures
on f6 and now what do you play here well
magnus definitely made some progress
here uh he's still leading on time it's
an hour and 17 minutes for magnus
whereas nipple is down to one hour and
six minutes
and of course knight to e4 we have to go
for this uh nipple has to start
developing his pieces he goes knight to
a6 with the idea of bringing the knight
to c7
but also uh knight to b3 now now looks
very interesting uh it's not you know
exclusive that the knight has to go to
c7 and this is one of the moments where
you really have to
consider what to play i mean you have to
do it in every position because it's a
very important game
but for example bishop the e3 here is
very very interesting and the point is
uh if uh white if black plays the uh
knight a to b for move which was which
was planned we're going to play knight
to e5 now and after bishop captures an
e5 d captures on e5 we're gonna uh see
this c5 move and yes this frees up
black's bishop which is very important
this is uh uh terrible for black to have
his bishop so uh so hemmed in we're
gonna play eight captures on b5 and now
it's uh you know it's a complete mess of
a position uh for example bishop to d5
and now we're going to play bishop
captures on c5 attack the rook knight
captures on c5 knight captures attacks
the queen and now queen captures on b5
we're gonna see bishop captures on d5 e
captures and now this is one of the
possibilities that could happen with
magnus ending up with a past e pawn
where nipple would have a past deep on
and it's it's a crazy position for for
example uh but after this knight to a6
move magnus did not go for bishop to e3
he said uh there's no need to prepare
knights to e5 we're just going to play
knight to e5 right away but there is a
big difference at knight to e5 was
played here and there's even a moment
a nice moment caught on camera of nippo
when magnus played this so we can check
it out just for a second so this is the
moment when anipo came back to the table
and saw that magnus played knight to e5
as you see
uh he he doesn't see the point and you
know he doesn't think much of it yeah
he's going to look at the move then he's
going to write down the move and then
he's going to contemplate on on what
he's going to do next
so uh now that we've seen this we're
going to uh you know enjoy nipple's move
uh a little bit more uh and here nipple
just captured the knight the point is uh
if if you go for queen captures on d4
which of course is a possibility there's
the problem of knight captures on f6
rook captures and now a captures on b5
attacking the knight here so there
really isn't anything better queen
captures on e5 queen captures knight
captures we're going to play b captures
on a6 and yes black is still up upon but
look at this terrible bishop here you
can no longer remain on this diagonal
you will not be playing c5 and trying to
trade off a white excellent light square
bishop you're gonna have to play some
sort of a passive move like bishop to c8
and now white with the bishop pair with
this beautiful pawn on a6 will have all
the advantage here plus black's c pawns
are doubled uh it's uh you know
it it would be hard to say that this is
not lost for black uh let alone that
it's uh you know a little bit harder to
play this so this is what magnus was
kind of going for but he completely
missed nipple's idea or maybe he didn't
uh we will have to ask magnus and c uh
bishop captures an e5 was played by
nipple as you've seen in the gif with d
captures on e5 and now knight eight to
c5 and now you can see this knight is
coming to b3 actually via the c5 square
and this will attack not only the rook
but also put a double attack on this
bishop on c1 and here both players
regarding clocks are around the one hour
mark so they've burned half of their
time and what do you play here uh the
problem is if you just trade let's say
knight characters knight captures and
play bishop to e3 knight captures an a4
comes and now you really don't have
compensation black spawns are just much
much stronger on the queen side uh you
really don't don't have anything here
so instead magnus spent his time here
and he played knight to d6 and while
this is an excellent square for the
knight it also means you have to
sacrifice the exchange and nipple goes
for it knights to b3
then the bishop is attacked twice the
rook on a1 is attacked so you will have
to give up the exchange whatever you
play uh but the problem is there is a
good way to give up the exchange and
that there is uh well a a lesser way to
give up the exchange and magnus i
believe chose the lesser way but it's
not all that easy to uh to see this or
maybe he didn't maybe he saw it and he
decided that that was the way to go uh
point is magnus played rook to b1 and he
forced nipple to capture on c1 and he
wanted the trade to occur on c1 but
there is a very interesting variation of
bishop to e3 now point is after the uh
knight captures rook for example in rook
captures on a1 uh there's the problem of
this uh
a7 pawn and the bishop on e3 really
nicely uh forces this rook to remain
here so at some point black will play
something like a6 and now we're gonna
play f4 uh so the point is black is up
the exchange but white has the bishop
pair and there's no way to get rid of
this knight and another thing there's no
way to play c5 for the moment uh as the
bishop on b7 would be hanging both the
bishop and the knight are attacking it
so black's only idea here would be to
play rook a to b8 but now our bishop on
e3 can play go to a7 we can attack the
rook and now
it doesn't really matter if you go to d8
we're just going to keep harassing this
rook and if you go back then we repeat
bishop to e3 so
this is never
any
risk for white so in order for for the
game to continue black will have to
choose something else uh but uh you know
if this was played nipple also could be
happy with a draw so well this is a very
impressive way to play uh unless uh
black wants to push for something
there's no way to play anything else
then go for a repetition here so it
would be very dangerous for magnus to
accept such a draw so instead after
knight to b3 he played rook to b1 and he
decided to give up his dark square
bishop which uh nipple of course very
happily takes and he took his time and
magnus is down some uh to some 48
minutes on the clock nip was still a
full hour on the clock and he captures
the the bishop uh we have knight uh b
captures on c1 rook b captures on c1
knight captures rook captures and now
very happily played rook 8 to b8 you
don't have to worry about that bishop
that no longer exists attacking your a7
pawn and now you are uh well you are
ready to push that c5 move and once we
trade the bishops then
it's hard for white to claim any
advantage here and here again magnus uh
uh has to figure out what to play he
played rook to d1 uh for example say the
norwegian supercomputer uh suggested
queen to g4 with the idea of h4h5 but
that's you know super computer ideas so
instead we have rook to d1 here and now
comes the bishop to a8 by nippo and
again this was the moment where uh you
could really uh seize the advantage with
black but it's uh it's such a crazy
position for those of you okay we can
even make this a pause the video moment
for those of you who have not seen the
game yet uh feel free to pause the video
and try to find the uh well an idea for
black here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
soul of silicon idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
b captures an a4 it looks looks crazy
you know just weakening your structure
like this but the point is after queen
captures on c4 we just play c5 now
that's the idea and the thing is yes our
e6 pawn is weak so white will go after
it threatening to win the queen we're
gonna play bishop the c8 and of course
we cannot capture the bishop because our
rook on d1 is hanging so we're gonna
move the rook and now of course the
black will play king to h8 get out of
this nasty diagonal we're going to play
queen captures on c5 and now bishop to
a6 and black is definitely now into the
game you no longer have to worry about
the developing
and after let's say queen to c2 because
we have to defend this b2 pawn we're
going to play rook to b3 and black's
position is beautiful all of a sudden
uh both of the rooks are now definitely
into the game uh the the the rook on f8
to very nicely placed bishop on a6 very
nicely placed so
this
is the way to go however it's a very
difficult move to not only to make it
some difficult move to consider because
why would you allow this you you you
have this position you're you're
thinking i want white to capture here so
i can undouble my pawns and you know
enjoy this position and interestingly uh
after this bishop to a8 move uh he
allows magnus to go for this knight
captures and b5 idea that's the only
capture you can make because okay the
rook and the queen are aligned on the d
file uh but he's not all that impressed
uh and the the the reason is after ninth
captures on b2 on b5 attacking the queen
you're just going to move the queen
there are some crazy lines here like
rook captures on f2 also just attacking
white's queen if queen captures you're
going to capture the rook here and then
after something like king captures uh on
f2 we're going to play queen to f7 check
and only now recapture the knight on b5
for example king g1 c captures on b5 and
now let's say bishop captures an a8 rook
after say captures on b5 but there's not
much to to do here this would be
um uh it would be a droish end game uh
so
that was in the position definitely but
magnus now starts creating uh attacking
chances and he plays bishop to e4 now
the situation on the clock it's very
important uh 33 minutes for magnus
against uh some 47 minutes for nipple
and you can see that already uh there
could be trouble here because niepo has
been spending all of his time trying to
you know get his bishop on the queen
side into the game you know trying to
keep that queen side intact but now look
at this the knight guarding f7 bishop
attacking h7 queen ready to come to h5
in the future rook to d for rook to h4
those are all very good resources and
the black has to be very careful on how
to uh how to advance here and while
there are many ways to to go about this
position for example the the
norwegian
just says g6 here but who would play
this i mean it's it's completely crazy
and now for example a5
also a weird move because you want this
pawn to be able to capture on b5 but the
reason is there there's no reason to do
it if black ever pushes c5 we're going
to capture on a8 rook will capture and
then the b5 pawn will be undefended
we'll always be able to capture this b5
pawn and now let's say queen e7 getting
away from the rook we're just going to
play f for now and this is how
uh how the game probably is supposed to
go but you know those are not those are
not human moves uh also very interesting
is just asics but a6 is uh is uh
uh is just a craftsman move uh the point
is uh you're saying but what about
bishop captures an h7 and it would be
very interesting because if bishop
captures king captures queen captures on
h5 king the g8 and now rook to d4 going
for this rook h for queen to h8
checkmate the knight still covering the
f7 square there's the very unpleasant
queen to a7 that's why a6 is so
unpleasant uh the rook cannot move
because of queen captures on f2 so even
this is in the position and the magnus
can't just go attacking you know
without checking stuff
uh so like i said instead after bishop
to e4 nipple did not defend nipple did
not uh the defense slash attack with a6
nipple plate c3 and this is now very
very interesting uh he wants magnus to
capture with b captures on c3 so he can
play b characters on a4 and have a pass
bond that's very uh well already across
half of the board
and the magnus doesn't capture
capturing here while possible uh he he
he first goes after the h7 pawn but it's
pretty much the same idea only capturing
right away would be better for magnus if
b captures an a4 queen c2 we attack the
h7 pawn let's see g6 and now queen
captures an a4 that's uh well it seems
much better than what actually happened
in the game because after c3 magnus
played queen to c2 first attacking the
the h7 pawn and now uh nipple just
defended it with the g6
uh we have b captures on c3 and now
comes the b captures on a4 but this b
captures an a4 now which transposes into
the position that we've already
discussed uh is not necessary here
nipple can play queen to g7 and this
queen to g7 move is uh is an uh is a
resource that nepo's been missing uh for
the better part of the second half of
the game as it's always in the position
it just
attacks the e5 pawn and it forces white
to play this f4 move and it's it's just
very useful for black uh that white
plays this move because after f4 uh the
king is now wide open and you no longer
have to worry about any rook lifts in
the future
and it's just something that that should
be done uh but okay nipple played b
captures on a4 instead and now queen
captures on a4 we've transposed into the
exact same position that we've discussed
a situation on the clock as i know you
guys are interested 23 minutes for
magnus and 33 minutes for nipple this is
only move 27 so 13 more moves have to be
made at
reach time control and for each player
to be given an additional hour uh we
have rook after d8 now the knight cannot
move as even though the queen defends
the rook the queen and rook will be
attacking that d1 square so magnus just
goes rook to a1 now he wants to grab
this a7 pawn
uh and here uh basically forcing c5
there's no other way to defend it
because you're just going to lose the
pawn so here nipple plays c5 and it also
comes with a tactic you can't just grab
the a7 pawn now
because if you grab it now then we're
going to capture and after rook captures
there's this incredibly unpleasant rook
captures on d6 move uh and it doesn't
matter now if you capture on d6 we're
just going to play bishop captures on e4
leaving us up a bishop and it also
doesn't help if we play bishop captures
an a8 we're just going to play move the
rook rook to d2 and it's still a
completely winning position for black
there's not much white can do here
so after c5 magnus goes queen to c4 he
still wants to keep the pressure
completely he still wants to put
pressure on the e6 pawn
but now of course bishop captures an e
for his played knight captures on e4 and
now uh he doesn't want uh his king to
remain on this diagonal nipple plays
king to h8 although queen to e7 was also
uh very interestingly regarding this
pawn guarding this bomb preventing
knight to g5 in the future uh nipple
prefers to move out of the way we have
king to h8 and now magnus just repeats
knight to d6 uh knight captures on c5
while possible it doesn't really give
all that much after queen to d5 you
would struggle you know holding this
position with white so instead just
knight back to d6 and now we have rook
to b6 now uh nipple is already uh
thinking about giving up a rook for that
knight because it's just a monster uh
there there's no way black will be
getting any counter play as long as that
knight is on d6 plus you always have to
be very very careful about knight to f7
check about 94 knight coming to f6 so
it's um
there's just so much this knight can do
we have queen captures on c5 and now we
have rook d to b8 now with some ideas of
rook to b1 check so king to g2 by magnus
and now a6 now the rook guards the pawn
on a6 very nicely and magnus uh also
brings the king to h3 so it looks very
dangerous but with the pawn on e6
there's really no way to threaten the
white king on h3 since black only has
the rooks you do not have a knight or a
bishop that could threaten the king on
h3 uh 10 minutes magnus 16 minutes for
nipple here and rook to c6 attacking the
queen magnus centralizes queen to d4
and now
again nepo will be going for rook
captures on d6 at some point and he
doesn't like his king
on this diagonal now because if pawn
captures it then the king will be uh in
danger so king back to g8 and now magnus
just plays c4 so now queen defends the
e5 pawn e5 pawn defends the knight
knight defends the c4 pawn
the rooks are absolutely useless against
this but it took magnus even more time
now it's six minutes for magnus and 12
minutes for nipple
and we have queen to c7 now the knight
can uh well uh
now the queen is no longer on on this
very very nasty square uh uh eyeing the
the white queen so here we have queen
the g for by magnus uh again queen to g4
is a move that uh
that
has a lot of pressure but it's uh
then again it's much easier for black to
to
equalize and you know completely uh get
any
uh
irregularities from the position because
here if you want to keep the pressure
and if you want to keep that knight
defended not allowing rook captures on
d6 you have to play something like rook
to a3 and hope to get rook to f3 and
then to do some damage uh but even
though this kind of keeps the tension it
also doesn't because you can bring the
rook back to you can play rook to f8 to
prevent rook f3 for example and now if
you play rook b3 to go rook b7 we can
just go back we're going to play rook to
b8 and now with rook to f3 we're going
to play rook to f8 and this doesn't
really give white all that much so the
only thing you could do after rook to f8
is play f4 to continue the game somehow
if you are interested in pushing this
but then just rook back to b8 and you no
longer have to worry about the f file so
again
another reason why it's
important for black to force the whites
to do this f4 move which nipple did not
do the entire game but
then again it seems to have worked out
very nicely so after queen to c7 magnus
went queen to g4 he goes after the e6
pawn and now nepo doesn't think twice he
just gives up the rook for this monster
knight on d6 with e captures queen
captures and now even c5 offering this
pawn for this pawn but nipple knows his
end games very well and he knows that
this is not a problem queen captures in
c5 was played queen captures on e6 and
now king to g7 and by playing king to g7
move 40 has been reached by both players
and they have now reached time control
and have been given additional time
magnus grabs the a6 pawn
and now he's up upon all of a sudden so
you can see that the magnet sacrificed
material to get that monster knight on
d6 uh controlling the entire position
and then for nipple to get back into the
game to gain some activity he had to be
down material so this is how you know
material
kind of kind of works in chess you will
give up material for activity and trade
activity for material
and now of course you don't want to
capture on f2 right away if you do this
then you run into something like queen
to e5 check and you lose the rook so you
know you have to
be very careful so rook to f8 this is a
a very a very important move and now
finally we get this f4 move uh we have
queen f5 offering a queen trade uh not
really offering you're kind of forcing
it we have queen captures on f5 rook
characters on f5 and now rook to a7
check we have king g8 king to g4 by
magnus so the king is very active but it
will not be all that easy to cross this
fifth rank so rook to b5 and magnus goes
rook to e7 he wants to play rook to e5
to cut off this rook's defense of the
fifth rank so his king can come up the
board now we have rook a5 rook to e5 and
now of course you cannot trade if you
trade the king and pawn and game is
winning for white you guys of course
know that very well so after rook to a7
magnus continues pushing with h4 we have
king to g7 and even h5 now hoping for
this trade for example if captures
captures then it can be a little more
dangerous as now white has a pass pawn
so nepo just plays king to h6 he wants
magnus to capture which of course magnus
does not he plays king to h4 and now
rook back to a1 so still waiting for for
magnus to make a move with g4 and only
now rook to h1 check king g3 and now g
captures an h5 saying that okay now if
you capture
i don't really care for example rook
captures we're going to play rook
captures g captures king captures and
now the king and pawnee game is is a
dead draw so after g captures on h5 rook
the e6 check was played we have to go
back king g7 now comes g5 this is how
magnus gets his pawns up the board
and nippon now has a past h pawn but uh
it is not a problem rook g1 check king
f2 now comes rook to a1
and now rook to h6 going after the h5
pawn and now rook a4 attacking this pawn
here so king of three defending it rook
to a3 with check
and now magnus has to go back king to f2
it seems like you can grab more space
with the king here if you go forward but
the black rook will just keep checking
your king e5 rook a5 check and now it
doesn't matter what you do rook to e6
rook to a6 check
king to e7 of course the black doesn't
even capture here black continues rook
to a7 check and there's no way to get
out of checks so after rook day three a
check king to f2 was played now comes
rook to a4 attacking this uh pawn here
uh and it was uh in this position on 58
that the players agreed to a draw as
there is simply no way to push this
for anything more than a draw
so really really uh exciting stuff uh
and uh it was a very intense struggle so
magnus definitely uh surprised nipple
with that uh knight captures an e5 move
in the beginning of the game
we can just whoops we can just uh
quickly
uh skip to that so this e5 was a it
wasn't like a really huge surprise i'm
sure nepal knew about the move at some
point
but then he
uh really really had to remember what
what the correct way to play this was
and there were a lot of very unpleasant
and very unnatural moves to play for
black here uh but nepo just uh continued
with all the human replies he played
them very well and uh you know it wasn't
possible for magnus to get anything more
out of this and then magnus again made
some uh choices maybe could have gone
better uh like this for example we
mentioned that bishop to e3 well it
seems very strong it doesn't give you
all that much uh and then you know it
was just uh
it was just a very very enjoyable game
and uh well yeah i did not i did not
think that we will have a game this
enjoyable in world championship match
even though a lot of you guys don't
enjoy when the games end in the draw
because it's not another interesting
game but you always have to think of it
like imagine if the game lasted up until
this point and then a player blundered
the rook and you know would it be an
interesting game because one of the
players won it would be the exact same
game only without the blunder in the end
but there are games where you know it's
a complete draw and then a player makes
a blunder and then it's an interesting
game but you know it's i don't think
it's a good way to look at things you
know this is a this is an incredible
game and it's um incredible that the the
players handled it so well especially
since uh they're playing without uh uh
an increment on time before move 60. so
that's a very important so if you're not
careful magnus was below 10 minutes uh
you know you're gonna run out of time
and that's it you're not gonna get that
extra 30 seconds that you you're used to
when you're playing classical chess so
this is very exciting their seconds will
have a lot of a lot of work to do
covering all of these lines if it will
be repeated in game four but now
tomorrow we get uh game three
and we'll see if we will have a
repetition from game one and who will
deviate first or or maybe we will have a
completely new and on uh you know
unexplored territory uh we we can only
imagine such things
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank happy
birthday rabaya uh mark hobert uh alvin
goodrich mikhail verolinen and michael
kennedy for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
chess championship uh until it ends uh
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
sorry for a bit of a longer video this
time uh see you soon